the commission's package on migration
and asylum
which we present today offers a fresh
start many legitimate interests have to
be brought into balance
we want to live up to our values and
at the same time face the challenges of
a globalized world
europe has to move away from ad-hoc
solutions
and put in place a predictable and
reliable
migration management system i'm
convinced that the commission's proposal
is a good foundation for that
this package reflects a fair and
reasonable balance between
responsibility and solidarity
among member states we all share the
benefits
we all share the burden this package
also reflects a very pragmatic and
realistic approach
we know that we have to build trust
among member states and
citizens confidence that we can manage
this
as a union the package reflects
the complexity of the issue as it brings
together
all aspects of migration border
management
and screening asylum and integration
return and relations with external
partners
it is not a question whether member
states should
support with solidarity and
contributions
but how they should support
moria is a stark reminder we need to
find
sustainable solutions on migration and
we all have to step up
the european union has already proven
in other areas that it can take
extraordinary steps to reconcile
diverging perspectives we have created
a complex internal market a common
currency
and an unprecedented recovery plan to
rebuild our
economies it is now time to rise
to the challenge to manage migration
jointly
with the right balance between
solidarity and responsibility